even sent us fake wire transfer uh
transact confirmations at one point
where he said oh
i've sent your account 500 000 go check
your account i sent you the confirmation
two three days later there's nothing
there's no money there's nothing the
confirmation is a made-up number
all of a sudden we get a phone call from
noor saying hey
i was supposed to collect this money and
this guy reaches out to me and says that
he got
robbed by gunpoint for 18 million
dollars
18 million 18 million dollars in a
pickup truck in a neighborhood or the
part of
jury one that is well known that he
never visits
so where's the police report never seen
it
never seen it oh my god this guy's such
a scammer dude
such a scammer i hope he rocks in jail
ladies and gentlemen welcome to 221c
baker street i'm your host coffee zilla
the internet detective and today
we are making our last in a long
playlist of videos on
jay mazzini hopefully the last hopefully
no more victims come crawling out of the
woodwork it's ridiculous
how many people that this man has
allegedly scammed now as a quick
reminder that
the amount of money we're talking about
today i i know we get lost
in the like oh is it 10 000 or a million
dollars
we're talking about the biggest loss of
anyone i have ever personally covered on
my channel okay
back in the day it used to feel like
five thousand dollars was a lot of money
to lose and it still is a lot of money
to lose
to most people but the numbers we're
talking about today we're talking about
3.5
million dollars allegedly lost or
defrauded
by jay mazzini the person we are talking
to
is one of the members of halal capital
one of the investors
who has not received his money has not
received his interest has been chasing
this guy down
trying to find him and i am stunned
absolutely stunned that this scam is
still
going on that still people are trying to
get their money back it's absolutely
horrifying and once again this is for
awareness but remember there are always
two sides to every story jamezini has
currently decided to be
uh completely silent his twitter account
has been deleted now
uh so thankfully he's not running the
bitcoin scam
as much anymore i don't know if he'll
continue to do it on his instagram
uh but my point is is that look he might
have things to say what we do know
for sure is that jay mazzini has
victims everywhere who are talking about
the fact their experiences with them and
overwhelmingly it's he scammed me with a
clothing thing
he scammed me with a bitcoin scheme he
scammed me with an investment thing
so that's the overarching um through
line with all of this
but i present to you guys today the
biggest
loss ever on coffeezilla 3.5 million
dollars i hope these people get their
money back
i hope the proper authorities get
involved but without further ado here's
the 3.5 million dollar jay mazzini fraud
allegation interview
ladies and gentlemen welcome to coffee
zilla today we're talking to muhammad
he's one of the victims of halal
capitals
basically uh co-founded by jay mazzini
and we're going to talk to him
about his story about the insane things
that happened how jay mazzini said that
he got
robbed at gunpoint we're going to get
into all of it first
i think everyone wants to know how did
all of this
get started and maybe i should start
with how much did you invest with halal
capital
so yeah bismillah
i'd like to start with the the name of
god the almighty allah
it didn't happen right away the amount
wasn't accumulated
uh one hand one shot basically was in
the course of
i'm gonna say five six months when uh
they approached us back in
november but by i'm gonna say by
end of may the
the principal amount reached about 3.5
million
that's massive yeah yeah
and right now you have not been paid
back your money
no not not the principal not earnings
anything no
oh the principle just the amount you put
in excuse me yeah just the principles
uh uh approximately 3.5 million yes
muhammad how did this get started and
you work in an
auto shop right is that right yeah well
the family owns and runs a
repair shop slash body shop and uh we
have also
we also sell cars basically we have a
dealership out uh
in you know various locations in
brooklyn new york so you know the
family's been my dad's been around here
since the 70s
we're well known in the community we're
uh you know we're well established as
far as businessmen and we're well known
and whatnot
that's awesome and how did you
run across uh the halal capital
so initially it started with uh a
community member
uh nur rabbah who was well known in the
community a
gentleman to to for the most part i mean
up until nothing really bad to say about
the guy other than the fact that he's a
funeral director and we actually
you can find videos out there that
probably show you me helping out at the
funeral and whatnot
back in november he approached us with
this business venture saying that
he just collaborated with this uh
individual named jamezini
now up until then all i knew of jay
mazzini or
uh ichibara uh jabara was he's
a instagram uh celebrity
and uh he gives to the poor he uses uh
religious um
speech to acquire that uh i mean to get
in
in in that face and what and now in that
matter and that's pretty much it and we
know that he
he he you you know he he accumulated his
wealth with stocks
and a an academy that he was well known
for
um so we said okay it's fine that's all
we know of him are you sure
that this is the type of business
venture that you want to get into he
goes yes i've even tried it with my own
money
and he showed us proof of how much he
invested and what the return he was
getting
we started small about 75 grand and
slowly uh reached up until the 3.5
now can i ask you how much was he
promising in terms of returns what are
we talking about here
in terms of like what are you expecting
on your money
initially initially all right initially
in november
started around 20 22 uh
per year uh well that was a three-month
three-month flip what they called it the
three-month flip
and uh slowly it became a
monthly return of anywhere from 15
to 10 anywhere from 10 to 15 oh yeah
that's a huge scam
there's no way listen we didn't know any
better i
i was young i mean i'm young and i
didn't know any better honestly but
we've always had a cash business
that we basically saw a product we sold
product
we sold the service and we accumulated
money that way
we were oblivious to this this type of
business that required us
to just drop money and return and get a
return on a monthly basis it was just a
whole new concept for us
don't know any better of course and also
you probably didn't think that this guy
you know uh using religion to come
and make make friends would you would be
lying to you
and would have any reason to lie to you
in fact it probably makes you trust him
more
oh absolutely absolutely and that and he
utilized
this particular uh uh person nuroba
to do that to do that very thing okay to
um basically you're well known in the
community when he approached them and
sometime in 2019 uh you're well
established and
to up until this point we we believe
that nour is
a victim as well there are faults
in uh everybody not to the
not to the incriminating factor of being
a scammer or a thief
yeah so tell me about so you met you
meet this guy you start dropping money
and
you start to see returns i mean have you
gotten these returns back
or is it like hey keep putting money in
with all paper trail it was all paper
trail basically um okay you dropped 75
000
you're up now 150. uh okay beautiful
but i'd like to put more okay put more
and drop the
the principle that you initially put
with the earnings and
it went on from november up until
um august when we were supposed to
collect our final
overall because we told uh we told newer
at the time hey we're not
dropping any more money we have no more
money to drop
this is the final uh thing that we can
drop we'd like our principal we'd like
to actually see
our money and be able to hold our money
and he said
given you're entitled to this that's
absolutely true we haven't you guys
haven't seen your money for months now
that's uh
that's a that's a an according request
so august 8b was supposed to collect uh
he tells noor that there's a delay
a few weeks go by we accept the excuse
all of a sudden we get a phone call um
from noor saying hey i was supposed to
collect this money and this guy reaches
out to me and says that he got
robbed by gunpoint for 18 million
dollars
18 million dollars 18 million dollars in
a pickup truck in a neighborhood or the
part of
jerusalem that is well known that he
never visits
back up back up because okay so in the
lawsuit that's been filed in the state
of new york
there is talk about a a robbery but no
one ever gives figures so he was
claiming
that he got robbed for for 18 and i
don't mean to laugh i'm laughing at the
absurdity of
what it he his his story he got robbed
for 18 million dollars that's what he's
his claim is yes that's what he wants
you guys to block
for 18 million that's not only it he
goes it could be more
because it was 9 to 10 duffel bags
and that he couldn't he didn't have
enough time to count the money
that was in the duffel bag he just threw
it in the pickup truck
let me permit me to ask the obvious why
was he carrying around 18 million
dollars in a pickup truck
we asked the very same question he goes
that was a norm for him
because he dealt in numerous or big
purchase orders of electronics
okay the uh obvious obvious total
fabrication total lie
of course this did not happen but and so
he's using this excuse
for what now does he say i fought a
police report or
so we asked for the police report he
says because that they were
cash dealings that he refused to uh
he refused to make a police report but
there was a police report because the
car got impounded
supposedly so where's the police report
never seen it never seen it oh my god
this guy's such a scammer dude
such a scammer so then we we
push uh sometime around august the 25th
or somewhat we push for a sit down with
his father we reached out to his father
we told us and this is unacceptable
your son is making these allegations we
need to come for a sit down two days go
by
after constantly pressuring them they
finally get us to come to sit down to
a family friend's house not even at his
house they're not even man enough to
bring us into their own houses they we
have to go see a family friend
i go there with uh me and uh nur and
two other individuals were greeted by
three
bodyguards for a simple sit down
for something that we're coming to
collect our our
our our rights basically so we we pushed
it off we said you know what
he's supposedly saying he got robbed he
finally feels on edge
it's fine whatever we go in
we go supposedly we go in and uh we just
you know we explain the situation what's
going on he
explains to us basically he got robbed
gunpoint blah blah blah blah blah
and uh he's just happy that he's alive
money doesn't make a man man makes money
and uh i'll be willing to
pay you guys this back we go wait a
minute how are you going to pay this
money back and how long have you been a
million dollars yeah that's a lot
he goes 18 million there's nothing for
me
he shrugs his shoulders he goes i have a
clothing i have a clothing company
and a uh a uh a uh a trading company
that's worth eight million dollars
um that you know i make that on a yearly
basis i've been
i've been doing it for the past six
seven years i can make it like this
and uh we said okay what's the payment
plan
how long are you gonna take to he goes
you know roughly if i had to guess about
eight months
you'll have all your money is he this
arrogant this confident
oh yeah you know he's a knucklehead he's
a knucklehead i mean i don't know what
it is
i don't know how he refused every uh
other
sit down after another two sit downs
that i had with him
he he's not good with confrontation he's
just a cyber
a warrior that's all he is that's all
he's good at we reached out to his
father
after that because we wanted another sit
down to see when we were getting paid we
were getting
you know pushed around constantly never
getting you know given dates
he even sent us fake wire transfer
uh transact confirmations at one point
where he said oh i've sent your account
five hundred thousand
uh go check your account i sent you the
confirmation two three days later
there's nothing there's no money
there's nothing the confirmation is a
made-up number can i tell you would you
believe it
i've been hearing this story from every
single one of the people is that there
are
false things getting sent they say he's
saying they're going to get sent
they're not saying now if you fake a
wire transfer is that wire fraud
i mean well we we've been reaching out
to adas and and
the district attorney and whatnot and he
is he's he's looking into that i mean
there's things that i really
can't you don't have to mention now you
don't have to talk about it yeah
but just to go a little further into the
topic you know at one point the dad and
the family were protecting him they were
saying hey
uh our son is not the thief it's norm i
was like okay that's very
simple to to because at now from august
up until october it's we're gonna pay
you back you just gotta wait you know we
have this legacy castle thing coming uh
going on in september uh he had this
like um like convention done where he
had these rappers come in
fabulous and ludicrous and uh
basically he was these are people to uh
potentially boost up his
image to show that he he's a he's a
prominent
figure or public figure he's that's
special he makes these millions that
he's able to
uh drag off 18 million dollars it's not
nothing right so um uh
we went there we showed our faces we
were there he was spooked out he didn't
want us there at all we reached out to
the dad because he kept
dodging us he kept blocking our phone
calls and whatnot the dad was protecting
him like that my son is not a thief he's
gonna definitely pay you back
blah blah blah blah blah dodges us he
doesn't even doesn't he stops picking up
our phone calls
at one point he says i can't control my
son we go and we reach out to
prominent figures of his uh tribesmen
now a little insight on
how our muslim culture works is um if
somebody carries your particular family
lame or clan's name
what that initially means is he's or her
are under that clan's protection and
that they're responsible for him
just because we're in america that
doesn't negate that right
you know that's something that we still
today if i would do something wrong
people would reach and they couldn't
solve it with me people would reach out
to my clansmen
and they would my head leaders and they
would solve it they would need to solve
it
for for their reputation so we did do
that some guy named
rahm each bar who owns the uh jewelry
spot in
uh in new jersey says hey i'll take care
of it he's not going anywhere i'm going
to have that sit down with you he's
definitely going to pay
papa nothing
then we discover why at one point
he knew uh at one point he was writing
checks
to the jewelry guy
so there might be a case where we where
there's some money laundering going on
between
wait who is writing checks to who jay
was writing checks
writing the jabar's writing checks to
the jeweler yes
yeah we did find out that he was you
know interacting with him
on other ventures he said that he was
owed money and that
uh uh jay got him for money and what not
and he was just trying to accumulate his
money back and that was the only reason
he would even let him
step foot into the uh into the jewelry
spot then we come to find out that he's
doing business with him and
at one point the money that was given to
him in cash was being put
into the jeweler's vault let me ask you
what's going to come of jay mazzini he
still has a platform of 900
000 followers he's still
doing this like bitcoin thing and it's
declining for sure
but he's trying to still get people with
this bitcoin thing
what do you see as the end game here
right because
he doesn't have the money i can almost
bet you he either lost it
or he made a stupid bet because he
thought he was gonna double the money or
something
otherwise he probably have paid you guys
back now or he thinks he's gonna get
away with i mean where do you think his
head's at you've dealt with him more
than i have
yeah i've sat with him again uh numerous
times because at one point we couldn't
get him
and his partner to sit down with noor
rabbah couldn't get we could for some
odd reason
um he didn't want to see him and he
didn't want to sit with him to reconcile
this so i was forced to constantly
be in between and record to try to
reconcile between them to try to fix
this issue
so all the victims especially me to get
my
money back where do i see this going
honestly i'm hoping to god
i hope he i hope he rocks in jail and in
every sit down that we have we have them
on audio they never say that they don't
owe us money
in every audio it's just give us time
we're gonna pay you back
we don't have it now our son is giving
these he's doing these ridiculous
giveaways
he has these um uh vendors
these vendors that he he that give him
million dollar credit line
when floodgates opened up and they said
hey we're not paying you back we don't
owe you money
it was our it was our partner that
robbed us and you got to go after him
uh technically you gave him the money
blah blah blah blah blah blah
then you know we said you know screw it
we're gonna we're gonna blow things
completely out of proportion we're gonna
we're gonna illuminate everything that
we've come uh
in light with especially with
information with the jewelers
information with
warehouses that were rented to to um
to box those stupid clothing uh
lines this ridiculous mazzini crap all
right
um i'll pay to give you forty thousand
dollars if you buy ten of my products
those ridiculous things
ridiculous ridiculous ridiculous and and
it was at that point when we called him
out for that because he said
uh you know i'm gonna be paying you back
from the clothing line and what i'm
making
we're like wait a minute based on what
we're seeing that's a scam you're gonna
pay us back with
other people's money that's a scam and
that's when he blocks completely
nobody was getting any answers from this
monkey
i have messages i have constant
um trying to threaten me and threaten my
life
and threaten my families my wife's life
he turned your wife
yeah saying that he's gonna send thugs
over to to my house
now let me ask you so you talk about
other victims um
the lawsuit mentions 10 million dollars
i've heard it could be more than that do
you know how much
total was invested in this thing i
believe i believe that number's accurate
as far as principle wise
but that's not what people were
expecting to right
to collect how much do you think was
like if if you actually
said how much everyone had uh
accumulated at that point
i mean you would have just you if you
had the money in almost a year it's
that's probably about a hundred percent
uh given what you were telling me about
like fifteen percent a
month some months twenty percent every
three months i mean you probably would
have
doubled your money seven million dollars
that just didn't exist
yeah i would have retired at 32 would
have retired
but it's okay man money will come back
we know that uh i mean
we we trust in our judicial system we
trust that you know there are
people out there that are listening that
do care about these victims and
are going to deliver justice there's no
way he's going to get away with it
absolutely not with it's not just i'm
the most vocal about it
uh and that's because i have a backing
of my own claim
well uh thank you so much for sharing i
mean i appreciate you speaking out and
yes
there are people watching there are
people listening and we do want to see
this guy
go to justice i hope whoever the proper
authorities get involved i'm just here
to shine a light on this because i saw
this guy
scamming with his clothing line i mean i
saw it way back then
and i was trying to blow that up and let
people know and now he's got this halal
capital now he's got the bitcoin scam i
mean the amount of
trails of victims he's leaving he
doesn't understand how serious this is
but i have a feeling he's gonna
understand that's the problem i don't i
don't understand why he plays the victim
card i mean i i
i i i looked at his post today you know
it's almost it's almost he believes his
lies it's almost
i don't know maybe it's almost
narcissist it's it's
it's weird it's it's unbelievable it's
unfathomable
well thank you so much for sharing
muhammad i appreciate it so much
thank you for shedding the light on this
guy and helping us do that absolutely
happy to anybody want to say anything
else
[Music]
good to see you man hey thanks guys
thanks for coming thank you
god bless you guys
wake up and smell the coffee